foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
all right
foreign
foreign
foreign
Trump was doing this with his personal
toilet but shakes
[Music]
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elephants and bathrooms
elephants and bathrooms what on Earth is
going on with Trump toilets
Trump's White House toilet
clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
United Church thank you very much
elements of bathrooms I'm worried about
my espresso machine I'm not
it's not a joke it's just I'm worried
about my lathe
outside
[Music]
I'm not a lawyer the lawyers are lawyers
the lawyers are lawyers the lawyers are
lawyers get rid of the machine I'm
trying for getting rid of the machines
just pillows who did this attack who did
the Cyber attack so you have you know
the good Geeks and they patch it up and
they fix it and they put up better
protection virus protection but here's
what my attorney said he said
[Music]
um
do you frequently go to Hardee's is that
a common place you go okay that's pretty
funny
that could be your headline the machine
I said I would have passed through on
the way to find a ride through it's
really incredible The Branding around
that she said no you're not getting my
phone I said arrest me I've done nothing
really so no we're not gonna arrest you
I sure you can do anything you have here
and you can do it you can do okay
get rid of the machine I've tried for
getting rid of the machine I'm worried
about my pillow no no that's the worst
thing for you because your cervical
nerves in your neck I will send you some
big Phyllis I'm worried about my legs
okay felt them down turn them into
prison bars
all right thanks Mike Take Care thank
you
mangoes my bags of mangoes
I love mangoes too
our bodies
my bag of mangoes now cost eleven
dollars and 99 that seems like a pretty
good deal bag of mangoes mango art
mangoes
what eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
[Music]
the Wisconsin crowd identified
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what you doing
[Music]
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is Trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample Trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election which is just
dance
[Music]
[Music]
water rushes out to see
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times as opposed to Once
dumps dumps
[Music]
[Music]
what is going on here what is go what is
going on here
then he went Donald Trump killed Donald
Trump I love Donald Trump but no more
dropped by the drop boxes are just so
bad no more drop boxes Dickinson
hologic and cephe cephahide
that was about a guy named a rhino named
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney real Beauty had
to give the American people their voice
back by building something called truth
truth essential
against Kate's law and he voted for
Obama
amnesty you know we've endorsed Dr Oz
we've endorsed
JP right J.D Mandel and he's doing great
I've had more investigations and Jesse
James Billy the could some of the
world's greatest cricket players from
suchin
tendulker to Veron
[Applause]
as the great religious teacher Swami
Vivek
what's that
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the uh
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation and God bless
United States thank you very much he was
awarded the broad star and the combat
infant trip and badge for his service we
have to keep our country gay people but
it's not I mean for some reason it's
just not great anymore if you care about
Law and Order look Law and Order in
normal times roughly 40 percent of fresh
vegetables at about 40 percent China
nambia's health system is increasingly
self-sufficient this is not about virtue
Recycling and signing and the great
generals and President Ulysses S Grant
he's done he's really come back a long
way over the last 10 years hasn't he
we appreciate it very much Tim Apple
when they gaze upon your semites your
seminites towering Sequoias they deliver
they swept and swept in you know that
sweeping it was Swift and it was
sleeping like nobody's
ever seen anything happen units of
plasma for plasma donate plasma into
failing New York Times by
Anonymous really an anonymous gutless
coward I may ask Marilyn Lockheed
the leading woman's business the teacher
should ever be allowed to teach
transgender to our children
no nobody has to have parental consent
and we will totally oppose the Biden
Administration
Administration uh he made some
statements rough statements uh on Jewish
you you heard them and you know them
well
and welcome welcome welcome I was
briefly muted because there is no better
way to start a stream than being muted
we are here today for an announcement a
day that Donald Trump claims will be one
of the most important days in American
history here on your screen you see
inside the not at all gaudy ballroom at
Mar-A-Lago in Florida
and moments from now
Donald Trump will be making an
announcement it is expected that the
announcement will be that he is indeed
running for president but the
circumstances couldn't possibly be more
different today than they were when
Donald Trump came down that escalator in
2015 and said horrible things about
Mexicans it will be very different
because the country has already seen
four years of trump as president it will
be very different because Donald Trump
has a potentially strong and by the way
increasingly leading in the polls
potential opponent in Florida Governor
Ron death santis
and
because it is not going to be the case
seemingly that Fox News is going to get
in line based on the latest reporting
that we have so I can't thank you enough
for being here we are going to learn
so much today about what our next two
years are going to look like and I can't
think of any better people
to see this with then all of you except
for the people were brutally Banning for
life on uh YouTube and twitch right now
because of horribly anti-semitic things
that you are saying about me but other
than that generally speaking I like most
of you and I think that that is a good
place to start we have a superchar super
chat here it's Mar-A-Lago open mic night
by the way am I the only one who feels
this 24 campaign has already been
announced 50 times worst kept secret
ever listen I I yes it's a poorly kept
secret and also there's like is there
any chance that Trump will announce
something different like for example
I'm going to go down or up to Georgia
and put all my energy behind Herschel
Walker like is there any chance that
that might happen is there any chance
they might install an escalator so Trump
might be able to trip and fall down it I
don't know I don't know but it is going
to be incredible and we have so much to
look at in the next few minutes minutes
before Trump speaks first of all thank
you to Jason sickmeyer for signing up on
my website I do appreciate that very
much we are going to have two years of
work cut out here
really very much so thanks to everybody
who's been signing up via twitch rated
Roy vaderette chunky strudel queen of
wildfire T Hill as well really
appreciate all of you we have a goal of
Sev of a hundred today we have a new
coupon code the coupon code is please no
more Trump I'll tell you a bit about
that later where do we start today
because there is really no shortage oh
I'm already getting emails from people
saying please give me a free
subscription
the only way to get a free subscription
is to go to davidpackman.com free
membership do not email me about free
memberships go to davidpackman.com free
membership okay let's get to some
elements first and foremost
we have a situation right now wherein
Trump is losing but not to 18 different
candidates each with one point okay
almost every new poll since the midterms
has DeSantis defeating Trump the
exception is this morning consult poll
okay which has Trump up 13 uh 14 sorry
but you've got the CWS research or
research polls they have DeSantis up 11
over scrumps
WPA intelligence did polls in Georgia
Florida New Hampshire and Iowa they have
death scientists ahead by anywhere from
11 to 26.
um legere
has DeSantis up to
um and then famously we covered this on
the pcast today that's what I call it uh
DeSantis plus seven in a yougov poll
which is a B plus pollster so the
highest rated pollster here
is yougov and it has DeSantis Plus
seven
DeSantis plus seven this is a very
different situation than we had however
many years ago additionally Trump's
speech has dramatically deteriorated
this was an interesting little compare
and contrast that our friend Aaron rupar
put together take a listen to this tell
me what you think of it because I don't
need anybody's money it's nice this is
the before okay paid anybody's money I'm
using my own money I'm not using the
lobbyist I'm not using donors I don't
care
I'm really rich I'll show you that in a
second time
and by the way
I'm not even saying that in a bracket
that's the kind of mindset that's the
kind of thinking you need for this
country so because we got to make the
country Rich it sounds crass somebody
said oh that's crass
we need okay this is the new Trump you
to be as bold and determined
as the immortal
general Douglas MacArthur
who knew that the American Soldier never
ever quits
after leaving the Philippines for
Australia at a low point
of the Pacific War in 1942
MacArthur famously had
I shall how many G's are in MacArthur by
the way return
because I don't need anybody's money
it's nice I don't need anybody okay
anyway so you get the point so certainly
a very different Donald Trump than in
times before Charlie with a super chat
says
safeahide beautiful message of peace and
love I like that let's look at it it do
I have your permission to look at a few
other things until Trump speaks because
we've got a little bit would it be okay
if I do that or do we just want to kind
of stare at each other between now and
then
whatever people want we can just stare
at each other if you want but okay let's
look at a couple other things
um here is Mike pillow pillow of course
is at uh Mar-A-Lago for the big event
today over 54 countries have now been
taken by the machines yeah he is not
taking these losses well
particularly not the losses in Arizona
listen to this we bought them they're
absolutely bought everything that was
done in Arizona they are caught and
they've caught them
what does that mean I have no idea I
just listen hip of the spear for
unraveling see there's tens and tens of
thousands of citizens that are looking
for a place to reach out they're going
to do sworn affidavits oh God here we go
again with the sworn it's it's like
Groundhog's Day what happened I don't
think there's a judge in this country
that can't say we need a new election
down there
oh this guy is so deluded I gotta have
him back on to talk about what happened
Zona and not just for Kerry Lake
remember they took Mark fincham's to
they took Blake Masters they were all
stalled and I don't care doesn't matter
what anyone says we already know this we
were watching it from the Edison report
we were watching it cyberly and and guys
he watched it cyberly what else do you
need okay so there's pillow on that and
then here is a an extremely agitated mic
pillow
continuing these rants that's impossible
never happened in history before
oh Mike Lindell you Mike Lindell you
know
um you know yeah we kind of are I mean
that is what we're saying you're a
little
you're living here
no you're sorry you lost it doesn't
matter how much money you spend on your
election
that ship sailed even his co-host is
like what the hell is this guy talking
about oh really then everybody then how
did how did these all these all get
taken how did all these how why wasn't
there Red Wing you can only have one
answer yes people voted for the
Democrats pewter manipulation how do you
get there guys it's impossible they're
they're trying to steal this from uh
from Kerry Lake and like they have all
the other races now Kerry Lake lost
that's all that happened now remember as
one we know that perfect Oz lost
mastriano he was front loaded we're
still they front loaded mastriano my God
so it sounds like he lost also no
running the numbers we're still we
thought we would have the
we will by Wednesday we believe there
was more votes than voters cast together
oh here we go again he pulled this on me
and you just we just looked it up and it
was like oh actually there were more
voters than votes yeah so it was totally
completely fine uh here's a guy who is
so disgusted with what happened on
November 8th
he is not going to uh vote ever again I
mean sounds pretty good you know in all
reality I don't have no reason to [ __ ]
anymore because uh the other day I chose
not to vote
and I'm never going to vote again
anymore in the remainder of my lifetime
however that must be pretty based
main reason is because back in 2020
as far as I'm concerned I lost all faith
in the Integrity of the voting system
right when my vote and your vote was
basically stolen and the goddamn
election was stolen all as well I like
that it was basically stolen oh so it
wasn't stolen bam [ __ ] Biden so you
know what I ain't vote no more and now
you got the GOP falling apart falling
apart crumbling like a goddamn Avalanche
they don't even know what the hell
they're doing anymore are they just
about as crooked as the goddamn down as
far as I'm concerned right I'm never
going to vote again in my life and you
know what I really don't give a [ __ ] you
know in all reality listen as I've told
all of you before I've said this many
many times
I would never start recommending people
don't vote but that just I I believe we
should have participation but vote for
competent people so for me I'm not going
to do a thing where I go oh don't vote
if you're a Republican but if
Republicans want to tell each other to
stay home because it's rigged I'm
certainly not going to get in the way
let them let them say that that's
absolutely and completely fine why not
uh that doesn't bother me one bit have
at it guys have at it
um okay
we are uh we are standing by for the
Trump announcement yes at the top of the
hour let's run through a few super chats
Charlie says safeahide beautiful message
Haley says soon to be Haley from
Maryland but I'm open to organizing
something in True Blue Augusta Georgia
before I move find me on Discord friends
we need to re-elect Warnock David sir
let's connect we cannot let Herschel
Walker win that seat and it's great to
see so many of our viewers in Georgia uh
getting engaged
Tian Comics says David your calculated
analysis during the midterms was like
the antacid to the indigestion-inducing
rhetoric of Maga now I know what Trump
meant by Massive dumps on Election Day
good thing I had my litter box ready
there's a lot more going on there than I
think I can necessarily weigh in on but
I do oh boy I do appreciate the support
I do appreciate the support
um let's see what else we got David sir
I'm watching you very strongly from a
cyberly perspective yeah is anybody else
watching cyberly
anybody
a couple people okay that's good
very nice very nice
everybody's watching cyberly okay good
uh let's see
sir any chance you and Stephen Kenneth
Destiny benell II connect to talk about
the Georgia runoff sounds like he's
planning an organizing effort appreciate
your conversations with him Obama I
would be glad to talk to uh Destiny
absolutely my favorite clip was when
pillow said he was staying up all night
and the commentators were crushed
I I did not see that but that that
sounds pretty funny over under for right
side broadcasting to show a half screen
ad for gold during Trump's announcement
I don't know probably like five minutes
in or something like that
um
that would be something
sir do you think Tucker Carlson would
make a 24 or even 28 presidential run
not 24 Maybe 28.
big fan David can you give a shout out
to my friends Nico and Lachlan I got him
hooked on the David packman show yes
Nico and Lachlan and thanks to Kyle
welcome to all of you welcome to all
y'all I appreciate that thank you to
Patricia porrup and Kevin combs for
signing up on my website really
appreciate that also big thank you to
Beth Graham your billion independent
Sam the sleeves bag jester bester
Diablo M Keith Berry in deciso
benevolent King
guitar goddess Lassie pushed me herself
at tall cross and Ja Chrissy that is
really appreciated and we are just
moments away uh from this uh probably
extremely uh dystopian and depressing
Donald Trump speech Let's Hear one
voicemail okay just one voicemail
to see what is on people's minds okay
let's see hey David
um just quickly was hoping that you
might be able to squeeze uh back into
the repertoire uh you drinking water
like how Trump drinks it with his hand
underneath it don't have to do it right
away after listening to those voicemail
but just something maybe slip back in
yeah yeah no what he's referring to I
think is when I would drink water like
this
which was the way we very strangely saw
Trump drink water I will try to slip
that back in I think if Trump if Trump
does run uh it is it is probably
something I should I should start doing
it is subtle
uh but I like it it's very very much
very very much up my alley okay couple
other things that I wanted to go over
with everybody another difference that
we are going to have this year if indeed
Donald Trump runs and yes look at these
guys is um there's already a civil war
going there are already people and in
fact let me see if I can go back to the
first one there was already a group of
people today
stomping on a DeSantis flag now I'm
going to be completely up front with all
of you
I don't know if this is satire let's
watch it I believe this these people are
for real but if this is satire let me
know
[Applause]
he's out he has plenty of time to gain
with her death so is is this for real or
is this a joke I can't tell
yeah
everyone decide on the Statue came down
hey me my father used to say to me he
used to say hold on he used to say son I
brought you into this world I can take
you out everything everything
so I genuinely can't tell whether this
is real at any point now after seven
years with a nice Trump display
uh we're very happy uh you know for the
announcement tonight so we're very
excited because we've been it's kind of
like on the down low since January 6th
but I think that gets all erased tonight
um you know I think the Trump supporters
are going to come out in the masses
yeah I really can't tell whether that's
real I I just I can't tell I don't know
what to tell you we've got a bunch of
different streams that we are monitoring
here
um right side broadcasting has a stream
um let's see if we can set this one up
Let's uh I want to get all of these
properly framed for you before the thing
gets going so that we don't miss like a
second of the idiocy
uh let's see here we go and there
and here
and we'll put it here there we go okay
good let's just listen to what's
happening in the room detail that
Mar-A-Lago has is really well it's it's
very trumpish it's exactly what I think
what one would expect a facility like
this to look like but we're glad you're
joining us and yeah extraordinary
facility you should see the HVAC that
they have it's really really something
else
um okay it's it's insane thanks to Sean
fertel Mark Fillion and Juan for gifting
subscriptions on my website if you want
a free membership just go to
davidpackman.com free membership also
welcome to Jester jokes and hey Michael
uh over on Twitch putting us at 23. if
you're just joining us the belief is
although we don't know for sure that uh
Donald Trump is going to announce that
he's running for president he's already
losing a number of polls to Ron DeSantis
and we will we will get to that okay
other things here was Marjorie Taylor
green I really like this Marjorie Taylor
green was asked why did Trump endorsed
candidates lose and here's what she had
to say Trump endures candidates
I would say there's I would say it
depends on the district I think there's
a lot of varying factors
redistricting happened and that was
based on the the census that was pretty
much pre-covered yeah so redistricting
affects congressional districts it
wouldn't explain why Kerry Lake lost it
doesn't explain why Tudor Dixon lost it
doesn't explain why
um Doug mastriano lost or Mehmet Oz or
whoever else of course redistricting
effects only districts and that's a very
strange explanation a lot of people
moved out of those districts over the
past two years I think that plays A Part
um I think it's candidate by Canada
sometimes one campaign has run really
well and sometimes one is not but I
would also say the media plays a big
part the media leans pretty hard left
and it was the media's fault it was
redistricting and the media's Fault when
Republican candidates when we run for
office not only only are we running
against the Democrat opponent we're also
running against the media a good bit of
the time and that's really not fair so I
think there's a lot of factors at play
and president Trump's win record uh is
is historic most of his candidates won
very few of his candidates lost
yes right and of course remember when
you mostly endorse
incumbents and people who are
um in very safe red districts it's
pretty easy to run up the record the
question is the contested races the
controversial races what happens there
and Trump's record is pretty bad by the
way I am I'm not going to spend a ton of
time on it tomorrow
but Tulsi gabbard
left the Democratic party like a month
or two ago and she endorsed 13
candidates and 10 of them lost like it's
immediately a horrifying endorsement
record and now I guess she's joining Fox
News it's wild it's the entire Tulsi
thing is a complete Fiasco all right
let's look at some other super chats
David do you have an idea on Trump's
pre-speech ritual I Envision a two liter
Diet Coke three Big Macs and a silver
tray with lines of crushed up Adderall I
can't confirm any of that
but I know exactly where you're coming
from A1 Andy that is that is that's
interesting that's very interesting
are you and Brian Cohen friends we we've
exchanged some messages would love to
see you guys do an episode together he
actually joined me on Election night
very briefly very very briefly
David sir for the first time I'm
considering buying a journal so I can
document what I expect will be an insane
two years I encourage you to do that it
will be an insane two years
bro I can't tell you how much I love you
and your post I feel like you say
everything I want to in a more
professional way thank you Anthony I
very much appreciate that
I hope the Trump announcement as he's
running as an independent that would be
delightful that would genuinely be
delightful I would love that would
destroy the Republican party's chances
Brian of right side broadcasting looks
like he has a Cheeto dust complexion
happening yeah he's a weird looking dude
block Dragon Here saw you with Dr Rashad
Ritchie not too long ago you two made a
great show hope you do a guest star on
John idarola's the damage report soon
the Red Wave was a red puddle would be
glad to be on John's show anytime oh my
God that's not Robert Downey Jr is it
please tell me Robert Downey Jr hasn't
gone Maga
that would be horrible is that Iron Man
no it can't be
that John McAfee
no can't be he's dead
wow what an insane event what a
genuinely insane event
um okay other super chats since the U.S
Constitution only says State
legislatures can make the election rules
wouldn't you agree that if a state
executive or Judiciary changed voting
rules unilaterally it would be
problematic no we've talked about this
already many times it's sort of it's all
it's like years old news we've already
talked about it
Scott says via Super Chat my name is
Trump King of Kings look on my Works ye
Mighty and despair nothing beside
remains round the decay of that colossal
wreck boundless and bear the lone and
level Sands stretch far away a beautiful
poem beautifully done
any guesses what's in the Trump mystery
boxes buttery males Sudafed nuclear
codes I did not see the mystery box
thing it sounds interesting though
I would love such a mystery box that
would be great thanks to Brian Gamez and
Mark Fillion for the memberships at
joinpakman.com ladies and gentlemen this
is I believe this is very clearly the
start of the 2024 presidential election
I know it's depressing because it's
seven days since the 2022 midterms but
DeSantis is crushing the polls Trump is
presumably announcing we don't know
what's happening with Joe Biden
this is going to be a crazy crazy
two-year period and I'm glad that all of
you are with me here we are welcoming
um closing in on 20 000 people over on
YouTube and closing in on 2000 on Twitch
and we also have people watching on
Facebook which is fantastic
um moments away at about 20-ish minutes
before Trump speaks let's look at
a couple other things oh wait a second
let me get set up here
with my other stuff I have stuff and
things for everybody here we go uh it
does look as though Roger Stone has
arrived at Mar-A-Lago he is there
for the big event
um
Devin Nunes is there
with a uh kind of an interesting look I
don't know I don't want to say too much
about it but it's certainly an
interesting look for Devin Nunes
um not surprisingly Trump's lawyer
Christina Bob just moments ago called
for a new election in Arizona why not
right if you didn't like the results
just do it over Terry Lake and her
campaign team and yeah quite honestly
abomade and the other candidates as well
that election was so poorly run and it's
up to that you know I'm not I'm not it's
not my team right but I think I think
they have a good argument to say the
election was so poorly run it shouldn't
be certified so you don't have a good
argument for that
I think they need a new election I mean
the only way to
restore confidence in the election in
Arizona is to redo it do it personally I
would like to see that happen you know
it's up to them what they do and if
you're Katie Hobbs and you're Secretary
of State and you're over the elections
wouldn't you think to clear and have
full transparency and to say you know
what if if I really feel like I won this
election I have no problem re voting
because I feel like my base is going to
vote me right make everybody revoke
beautiful wouldn't you think she'd be
open to a revote well I don't think
anybody who wins an election wants to
redo it I don't think she's going to be
open to it I don't think she's going to
do anything transparent should she
though oh of course absolutely
especially when you have a third of the
machines go down on Election Day so
yesterday they were saying it was
one-fifth now they're saying it's a
third Trace Havoc says David check out
this tweet apparently Trump just filed
to run ladies and gentlemen I have for
you right now the FEC declaration from
one Donald John Trump if you can believe
that President Donald J Trump yes
exactly uh this is the filing this is
FEC form number one Donald J Trump of PO
Box 13570 Arlington Virginia
has filed to run for president 2024.
his Campaign Committee is the Trump save
America joint fundraising committee the
custodian of Records is Bradley crate
the treasurer is Bradley crate and the
money will be handled by Chain Bridge
bank in Lachlan Avenue McLean Virginia
ladies and gentlemen this is indeed the
filing forthcoming is President Trump's
announcement presumably just moments
away moments away
and a lot of people said he's not going
to file
but it looks like he is indeed doing it
looks like he is indeed doing it hmm hey
David it's Jason from Pennsylvania uh at
Mar-A-Lago I wonder if sir ex-president
Trump will have his favorites from his
uh
his
okay yeah so we're moving on from that I
do wonder whether Trump Just For Old
Times Sake will attack Mexican supposed
rapists during his announcement speech
if you're just joining us if you were
just joining us we have found an FEC
filing filed just moments ago by one
Donald J Trump to run for president in
2022. Trump's speech will be in 23
minutes he is believed to be expected to
make about a 30-minute speech
um there was controversy as to whether
Jared and Ivanka would be here rumors
are Jared and Ivanka don't want Trump to
even do this they don't even want Trump
doing this
um so that is just moments away all
right so I'm glad everybody's with me
let's continue looking at some of these
super chats will there be indictments
anytime soon you know Kathleen I think
so
but what do I know
what are the chances this turns into a
full-on rally where Trump spends 90
minutes victimizing himself before
making the announcement at the end no I
don't think so it's reported Trump's
going to go no more than 30 minutes
thank goodness
David sir have you heard about missiles
hitting Poland yes we'll be covered on
the show tomorrow
do you think Liz Chinese should run as
an independent if Trump is the
Republican nominee
um
I don't know about that I mean if does
Liz chain even want to be president I'm
not sure
enough to think let's wait and see let's
let me let me let's let this digest
first
who was listed as chief executive
grifter that's Trump himself of course
no doubt about it thanks to Pac fans as
well as yo Samurai and Alice for the
twitch Prime subscriptions welcoming
nearly 2 000 twitch viewers we have not
had 2 000 twitch viewers live for a very
long time also so happy to have nearly
20 000 people watching on YouTube maybe
we will make it to that twenty thousand
dollar uh twenty thousand uh viewer
number
um Donald Trump is going to be
announcing at the top of the hour based
on everything we've seen has made an FEC
filing the Mar-A-Lago uh Ballroom which
as you can see it's a very gaudy room
which is Trump's style
um is I guess we would say packed with
people right
sort of like it's pretty pretty full
um
and the statement will be starting
indeed at the top of the hour
okay we got to that already
a couple other
voicemails
coming in
I'm really hoping
oh my gosh I hope this doesn't get
played uh
can I hit the pound to turn this off I
think I can
oh God don't play this sorry I made a
mistake well I'm I'm sorry it's
it's a bit too late it's a bit too late
I am very very sorry let's
um
what is happening here
there's folks saying that some some
elements of the stream are a little bit
laggy
we're gonna keep I'm gonna close out
C-SPAN
and let's see if that helps us in any
way thanks to Molly Brown who just
signed up at joinpakman.com I very much
appreciate that also thanks to I'm
scruffy for the twitch Prime
subscription okay let's go back to sort
of our our like list of things that have
been going on here
um down at down in Mar-A-Lago uh let's
see what else we have
what's this I was always loyal to
president Donald Trump he was my
president and he was my friend does
Trump have friends I didn't think Trump
had friends he doesn't seem like that
type of guy here's Mike pillow in the
ballroom at Mar-A-Lago with some kind of
prediction here we are live at
Mar-A-Lago look at all the fake news
from around the world I just had a ball
with them uh conquered to almost all of
them uh they asked me about uh Rhonda
Santos running against Donald Trump and
I said after tonight Ron will just
endorse him in the morning you gotta
believe
does anyone in my audience think that
tomorrow morning Ron DeSantis is going
to
endorse Donald Trump does anyone anyone
anyone anyone
think that that's gonna happen
I do not think so
jeez
quite frankly not making any sense
whatsoever
um
Madison cawthorne is at the event
apparently okay he sort of disappeared
after losing that primary a bunch of
other Trump groupies are there groupies
of different sorts jeez it's all pretty
wild I'm not gonna lie
it is uh it is truly something else
um people are saying something is up
with the stream I don't I don't know
what is going on with the stream
everything's fine here
we don't want to miss the announcement
but everything is looking completely
fine
uh
uh yeah like
wow
yeah it's it's beautiful gigabit like
beautiful beautiful gigabit is going on
here so I don't know I might just try
refreshing but like
we couldn't have a more beautiful
internet connection here up and down is
just blasting
um
I don't know
uh yeah
I am looking at everything and it's just
everything seems fine here I I wish
there was something clear that I could
do
uh as we stand by here
super chats continue to come in David my
pillow dude is hacking your screen did
you know he was such a tech guy I did
not
I did not
but that is interesting thanks to
makawaka and living vertex as well as
Lily and Gammon damage for the twitch
Prime subscriptions if you're just
joining us you have not missed the
announcement the announcement is 15
minutes away 15 minutes away and it is
going to be
uh extreme this is going to be quite an
extreme announcement
um
I was saying there's still lag here I
really don't know how there could
possibly be lag we are on just an
explosive explosive
internet connection
couldn't be faster
really couldn't
I could uh
let's see if I go live
I don't know
it's seeming pretty fine when I monitor
my own stream
yeah
can I turn down the quality I don't
think so
uh we look at settings
yeah
I mean it's
bitrate is a little bit low
it doesn't seem to be all twitch because
there are people complaining
um
there are people complaining on YouTube
as well now I'm getting a message that
stream quality is good try refreshing
once okay try refreshing once and then
let's see what we get
because it uh
I'm getting messages that it's all fine
okay all right let's uh let's take a
listen here we are standing by for the
start of this event uh let's listen to
what CNN's got going on information
which is there Carl Bernstein appreciate
it thank you as we look at Mar-A-Lago in
preparation for the former president's
announced and also consider Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis is clearly feeling
confident after his big election Victory
pushing back today on the former
president will tell you what he said
next means a lot
all right so they are uh following that
there which is which is pretty
compelling stuff not gonna lie and we
are just 15 minutes away 15 minutes away
from the start
of this so if people are saying that I
could do something but if I if I turn
off the stream we'll just lose all the
viewers that doesn't really make any
sense
that wouldn't be that wouldn't be smart
does Trump not care anymore RNC
threatens to stop paying his ongoing
legal bills
uh no I mean at some point he's gonna
have to announce if he's running
um
if people rewind 30 seconds behind live
it's better
did you have a blue chat mark on Twitter
now what's David you have a blue check
mark on Twitter now what's next
yeah I don't know about that
that's not uh that's not super clear to
me
let's see if we look at stream
everything's looking fine here yeah
there's literally no setting I can
change
quite literally no setting I can change
okay
all we can do is hope it Smooths out is
there any other Republican candidate
that would unite the left Imagine The
Campaign ads full of January 6th images
Q Anon memes he shared Etc
um
I don't think there's any Republican
candidate that would unite the left that
would no I don't think so
I don't think so
shout out for the 48 000 academic
student employees throughout the entire
University of California system who are
now on strike for decent pay important
very very important
my beautiful beautiful two gigabit
internet is buffering you perhaps you
need to make your internet great again
cheers on the excellent content thank
you
I'm in cyber as Mike pillow would say
you have too many viewers per year setup
to broadcast on this many platforms guys
I hate to tell you that doesn't make any
sense the number of viewers of my stream
I'm not streaming to each viewer
individually that's that's absurd that
has nothing to do with it I I hate I'm
sorry sir because you're a cyberly
person
that has nothing to do with anything
that has nothing to do with anything
David sir what do you think about
mandatory voting hope you and your new
family are healthy and happy thank you
folks we are seeing the streaming bit
rate go up dramatically all of a sudden
so maybe things are improving okay
there's nothing really that I can do
it seems to be maybe it's something with
restream I I don't know people are
saying when they refresh that it's
better
and
um I I just don't know what else is
really possible to do
um I can look at settings
it's all
I I genuinely think we're going to be
okay
I think it's just a glitch
oh people are saying there's no lag just
refreshing there's no lag okay all right
listen let's
let's continue Okay let's listen to what
marjorie's saying that is America First
that the Republican party will be the
party that they can trust for their
children's feature and for the future of
this country the past two years have
been unbelievable in what we have lived
through under the Biden Administration
and under Democrat control Americans are
fed up with it with people everywhere
hardly able to afford food gas rent
because of inflation that's crippling
Americans a wide open border that has
led to over 5 million people invading
our country we have a daily Invasion
fentanyl killing over 300 people every
single day crime is out of I don't even
understand why Marjorie Taylor green is
making an address does anybody know what
this is this doesn't make any sense to
me that burned American cities we have
we have Americans that have been charged
for January 6 and they're rotting away
in jail every single day pre-trial they
haven't even been
that is pursuing and spending tens of
billions of dollars defending another
country's border over in Ukraine and
completely ignoring the daily border
invasion in our country so I think this
is a little too weaponized guys I don't
I can't feel I just don't feel good
showing that to you it's it's just it's
just completely whacked okay this is
insane it's absolutely insane CNN also
monitoring the event everybody's
monitoring it okay let's reset we are 10
minutes away from the start of this
event from what we have found Donald
Trump did indeed find
uh file to run for president in 2024.
we found an FEC document that says Trump
is running so it's does not appear to be
a matter of if Trump is running it's a
matter of
when is he going to announce it
um William asks whether we've published
the white paper yet it's we are days
away the white paper is done the PDF is
being laid out we're setting up a system
to get it to everybody it's going to be
great I will tell you when the white
paper is live
sir my apologies for the messed up
voicemail lost my train of thought
mid-call will start writing it down it's
good to write it down I I would write it
down will Republicans hold their noses
and vote for Walker without the Senate
at stake I believe Walker will lose
but it will be close
we will talk much more about
Pennsylvania believe me believe me
um folks tonight is the start of the
2024 election tonight tonight it starts
with Donald Trump's forthcoming
announcement
I want to make one pitch and one pitch
only to you
we're going to be here for the next two
years covering everything covering
everything
we can't do it alone
I would love for you to sign up on my
website okay
it's dirt cheap
we have a discount code please no more
Trump okay this funds everything we do
the streams the voicemails the cyberly
bill everything okay
it's all funded and staff salaries
benefits health insurance the whole
thing okay we're really doing it here
this is a full-time job for multiple
people
go to my website
hit the sign up button coupon code
please
no
more
Trump oops I misspelled it Trump okay
boom
discount okay my lawyer is saying don't
do this discount my accountant is saying
don't do this discount this discount's
insane okay I don't care we're doing it
we're doing a discount
joinpakman.com
we will start filling this bar to a
hundred
three people just did it thanks to Greg
Mondello Jesse Holt and Marianne Foster
see how simple that is three people sign
up then it's 34 plus three hold on 34
plus three
37 and there it is if you were watching
on Twitch where we have NE we haven't
had 2100 people watching on Twitch for a
very long time
if you have Amazon Prime
you can get a free twitch Prime
subscription you're basically taking
five bucks from Jeff Bezos and sending
it to us okay
if you have Amazon Prime do the twitch
Prime thing we are approaching 2500.
on Twitch
we are doing everything we can as far as
the stream goes please refresh
please refresh
people in the chat thinking they know
what's going on there's something about
the CPU my CPU is fine we're using six
percent CPU it's something about the
number of people chatting on YouTube it
has nothing to do with that it has
nothing to do there's something up I
believe with restream just refresh it
mostly fixes it I'm looking at the
bandwidth and the bandwidth really is
okay
the bandwidth really is okay
all right everybody we are moments away
here couple other
uh uh voicemails uh actually no let's do
super chats David it's happening pillow
was right the stream is being taken by
the machines
love you Dave I'll tell you what I would
do with student loan forgiveness finish
my MD in transgender right
David what do you think Governor Abbott
is doing in Texas what is he doing in
what sense like literally right now I
have no idea
I think he's not helping the state out
very much that's for sure
I think if Michelle Obama ran in 2022
she would crush Trumper to Santa's
Michelle Obama has high favorability
it's not it's not as insane a statement
as you might imagine that's for sure
Marge is going hard for Trump's VP yeah
Marjorie Taylor green is desperate to be
Donald Trump's vice president desperate
when pressed they can't even really say
how they've suffered under Biden well
they say inflation and high prices
usually and like a shaky stock market
that's often what they say
MTG wants to be Trump's VP absolutely
she does
it seems like when you started playing
the interview your stream started
lagging maybe downsize the quality on
the video you were playing yeah I don't
know what is uh
I don't know what's going on here
but we are I I genuinely don't think
that that's the issue
let's see if we can get a
Newsmax YouTube see if we can just find
Newsmax maybe Newsmax is a
yeah let's let's go with Newsmax because
I do actually think that algorithmically
YouTube is just more efficient at
transmitting video and then we've also
got the CNN
feed
the America first movement in 1940 with
the Republican party and the Nazis isn't
talked about enough I've talked about it
I've talked about it
thank you to Dana Moore for subscribing
at joinpakman.com your new member number
38 I appreciate that also thank you to
motorcycle life for the twitch Prime
subscription as well as big Bulldog
putting us at 40.
also if you were just joining us we are
going to have we're going to have
everything we're going to be covering
everything remember that you are able to
subscribe absolutely for free on YouTube
we are powering towards 2 million
subscribers look at these beautiful
numbers folks look at that
look at that it's like one of those slot
machines that the old folks love
it is wild out there it is truly Wild
um
okay yeah the Trump announcement is
indeed at the top of the hour
any second David what are your thoughts
on Governor Andy Bashir of Kentucky as a
possible presidential candidate you're
not the first person to mention this uh
I think it's super interesting I just
don't know if the idea there's been this
idea for a long time you pick a southern
Democrat and the Republicans will
consider voting for them and so will the
Democrats
it's almost cliche at this point
it's almost cliche at this point but I
mean I think he's interesting I think
he's interesting
um my Nixon Republican Dad when pressed
said he wouldn't vote for Trump if he
ran in 24 for a third time I guess we'll
see we will find out very soon we will
find out very soon shout out to Illinois
passing the workers rights amendment
back your union
shout out
okay thanks to Mrs Coyne Dango in
Candlelight and DJ White Rabbit as well
as Dave director for the twitch Prime
subscriptions very very much appreciate
that
uh what is the coupon code folks the
coupon code is right above my head it's
please no more trump it couldn't be
simpler it's a message of peace and love
please no more Trump
please no more Trump
um
folks
refresh the stream and I'm being told
that it is all good here we go
ladies and gentlemen
it's starting
[Music]
all right welcome back uh to newsmax's
special coverage of Trump's big
announcement live from Mar-A-Lago we
just actually we've got another camera
that's watching the door uh for the
entrances and it's that camera right
there we just actually during the
commercial break saw uh Jared and Ivanka
Eric Trump uh Baron Trump actually all
walking it's notable that Jared and
Ivanka are there because it was not
clear they wanted to have anything to do
with this so that is actually relevant
and interesting
um folks memberships are dumping in
thank you thank you to Sean Wright
Jonathan Schwartz Lee McConkey Kyle
Geisler and Ted Cruz all of whom just
signed up on the website thanks to
everybody who is joining us today for
what I believe is indeed the start of
2024.
the start of 2024
is happening moments from now we have
already learned that Donald Trump
moments ago filed an FEC uh notice that
he is indeed a candidate and he is going
to be speaking momentarily
uh it is
dystopian and horrifying to many and I
completely understand that folks for
people saying the stream is behind
please all you got to do is refresh
people are saying the stream is now fine
just just refresh
it just just refresh
people are saying there hasn't been
buffering for 10 minutes
um we are moments away here from Donald
Trump moments away if you're just
joining us oh geez folks I am flattered
by what is happening on my website
the coupon code please no more Trump is
getting used more than Trump pleading
the fifth Cody to eat a poo
Michael quietkowski Jared Cardinal Chris
Sams Cameron Roberts William Determan
Rolando Bermudez Allison Armstrong
Mercedes schlapper
Sarah zintek Jeffrey Shulman Anthony
Victorio Eric Hendricks
and Scott
pitzinger all signing up on the website
folks via twitch Prime are just dumping
in subscriptions like crazy looks like
another 11 putting us at 70. really
appreciate it listen they're doing the
thing and we're doing our thing we have
no other choice these are these we don't
choose who we get to run against and it
looks like it's gonna be trump super
chats continue coming in maybe the
stream is buffering because YouTube is
repressing us maybe
what's your favorite song when times are
rough don't really have one I can't
really say I I wish I had like a clear
answer for that
the stream was spotty but I restarted
and now it's coming through strongly
very good
fellow Creator please check out bill c21
in Canada Banning Airsoft
I will look into that if I have the time
thank you
a quote I read on Reddit the Republican
Party should be forced to carry Trump to
full term even if it kills them thanks
for the content sir cheers appreciate
that
appreciate that
David say hi to my husband Connor
buffering but just rewind 30 seconds I
messed up two super chats here's a third
worth it thank you gurusum I appreciate
you being here we are just moments away
moments away I don't even think I can
thank everybody who is signing up right
now I'm not even gonna try okay I will
fill the number in when Trump starts
speaking I don't want to take any time
away I see that memberships are dumping
in insanely
and our incredible oh these people don't
know what the hell they're doing yeah
it's gonna give us better audio so we
don't have that issue uh Donald Trump's
scheduled to speak right now people look
titillated in the room we know I believe
I can say we know Trump is announcing
he's running because he just made an FEC
filing that he is running
uh
uh and so that is all going to be
happening momentarily
a lot of flags in the room that is
absolutely true a lot of flags in the
room David sir congratulations you're
the first person ever to say let's go
with news max I appreciate that let's
see what's happening oh Dick Morris is
in the room back host of Dick Morris
democracy dick great to be with you we
were kind of the return the return I'm
sorry the return Dick Morris author of
that book and Dick we were kind of a
half joking where what chapter are we at
in the return now with this uh where we
where we see this candidacy progressing
The Comeback tonight he announces his
candidacy and he sets himself on a
trajectory to win and talk to us also
too what do you account last Tuesday
night what do you man dick Morris is not
looking good huh what do you account
that to nothing gets me more Angry than
people thinking we lost
we got we beat the Democrats by Five
Points among house voters people voted
for the house we got 53 million votes
they got 48 million we guys it's bumming
me out to see Dick Morris like this I
have to say
this is actually bumming me out I I
don't I I don't know I just
this is kind of weird
I'm gonna refresh this just out of
curiosity because it says yeah how weird
is it that it's actually three past the
hour but Newsmax says that it's two
minutes before the hour isn't that
really strange
very weird
very very weird because that's not
actually the time that it is right now
Newsmax is behind interest man
everything is going wrong huh
really odd
yeah
we can pull up the CNN live feed just to
see if it's any different but it seems
uh it seems that everything is going
wrong here
this is the CNN feed
oh here we go very special occasion at a
very special place
you and all of those watching are the
heart and soul of this incredible
movement and the greatest country in the
history of the world it's very simple
apparently right side broadcasting
crashed as well
like it
this great movement of ours
never been anything like it and perhaps
there will never be anything like it
again there's never been anything to
compete with what we have all done
ladies and gentlemen distinguished
guests and
my fellow citizens America's comeback
starts right now wow
wow
two years ago when I left office the
United States stood ready for its golden
age our nation was at the Pinnacle of
power prosperity and prestige towering
above all rivals vanquishing all enemies
and striding into the future confident
and so strong
in four short Years everybody was doing
great men women
African-Americans Asian Americans
Hispanic Americans everybody was
thriving like never before
all right
there was never a time like this we
turned the page on Decades of globalist
sellouts and one-sided trade deals
lifted Millions out of poverty and
together we built the greatest economy
in the history of the world
when the virus hit our Shores I took
decisive action and saved lives and the
U.S economy and by October of the same
year America was roaring back with the
number one fastest economic recovery
ever recorded how about that
all of the incoming Administration and
all they had to do was just sit back and
watch
inflation was non-existent our Southern
border was by far the strongest ever
and because the Border was so tight
drugs were coming into our country at
the lowest level in many many years
importantly after Decades of rising
energy costs the United States had
finally attained The Impossible Dream of
American Energy Independence which soon
would have turned into energy dominance
okay
for the first time in memory China was
reeling and
back on its heels you've never seen that
before
because the United States was out doing
them on every single front and China was
paying billions and billions of dollars
in taxes and tariffs the farmers know
that because they got 28 billion of it
no president had ever sought or received
one dollar
for our country from China until I came
along and we were getting hundreds of
billions of dollars
many people think that because of this
China played a very active role in the
2020 election just saying just saying oh
God here we go sure that didn't happen
instead of jobs and factories leaving
America for China they were for the
first time ever leaving China for
America
[Music]
[Applause]
businesses were pouring back because of
our historic tax and regulation cuts the
biggest in both categories in history
bigger even than what Ronald Reagan was
able to produce and he produced a lot
China Russia Iran and North Korea were
in check
and respect it they respected the United
States and quite honestly they respected
me I knew them well
The Vicious Isis caliphate which no
president was able to conquer was
decimated by me and our great warriors
in less than three weeks and al-baghdadi
its founder was hunted down and killed
North Korea had not launched
North Korea had not launched a single
long-range missile since my Summit with
chairman Kim Jong-un nearly three years
before we developed a relationship and
that's a good thing not a bad thing it's
a good thing
very good thing actually because look at
what's happening today
my opponents made me out to be a
warmonger
and just a terrible person who would
immediately go into war
they said during the 2016 campaign that
if he becomes president there will never
be a war within weeks and we will have
wars like you've never seen before it
will happen immediately and yet I've
gone decades decades without a war the
first president to do it for that long a
period
the world was at peace
America was prospering and our country
was on track for an amazing future
because I made big Promises to the
American people and unlike other
presidents I kept my promises I kept
like the wall the health care plan all
that stuff right
oh my God he's doing the water he did
the water thing
[Applause]
thank you very much
under our leadership we were a great and
glorious Nation something you haven't
heard for quite a long period of time
we're a strong nation and importantly we
were a free Nation
but now we are a nation in Decline
we are a failing Nation for millions of
Americans the past two years under Joe
Biden have been a time of pain hardship
anxiety and despair
as we speak inflation is the highest in
over 50 years gas prices have reached
the highest levels in history and expect
them to go much higher now that the
Strategic National reserves which I
filled up have been virtually drained in
order to keep gasoline prices lower just
prior to the election
Joe Biden has intentionally surrendered
our energy Independence there is no
longer even a thought of dominance and
we are now begging for energy help from
foreign Nations many of whom find us
detestable
our Southern border has been arrested